>> AND THE REFEREE HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH DJ SMITH.
THE LAST 7 GAMES AGAINST THE
RANGERS IN OTTAWA. FOUND
CENTERMAN AND A BRILLIANT PLAY..
>> TAKE YOUR WORD FOR IT.TIPS IR
GEORGEEV AND OTTAWA WITH
ALEX
TIRED,
HE HUNCHES OVER AND CATCHES HIS
BREATH AND FINDS D TO
D FOR THEM. FOR 20.
CH SHOOTOT REIGNING NORRIS W PON
THINGS UP. BACK WITH THE FACE-OF
AGAINST
CHABOT.
DROPS IT B B
HERE.
>> TROUBA, STEPS AROUND GOODROW.
>> THE PASS COMING UP ON THE RET
>> ANOTHER JAB AT PAN I GO.
SKATE.
AND NORRISNSIDE
POSITION, HE PULSE IT OVER AND
THINKS HE H BACK
IN.
SHAW STEPS INTO HIM.
NOW
HE LOOKS FOROX WITH A BEAUTIFUL
SPINORAMA AND
FOUR-ON-FOUR.
IN COMES KREIDER.
TVNOR BROWN LOSES HIS METE.K INE
PENALTY.
CHRIS KREIDER.
AN EXTREMELY